landmark court decisions seized an
australian child from parents after they
refused requests for a gender change
the couple are appealing and one they're
being bullied into granting consent
the authorities say we will not allow
her to change gender so it's dangerous
for her to come back to our house
because we will mentally abuse her they
want us to consent to testosterone
treatment
the child who cannot be named for legal
reasons was born female but at 15
told family members about wanting to
become a boy when the parents refused
the child contemplated suicide in online
posts and was seized from home
by protection services it's not the only
case when parents clash with authorities
on gender
dysphoria a mismatch between people's
sex at birth and their gender
self-identification early this year
another australian child was allowed
feminisation
treatment despite the mother's
opposition previous rulings had left the
final decision to parents
my colleague sasuke taylor discussed the
issue with guests
you take a child at their most
vulnerable age and you take them out of
what is secure
we all know that teenagers make rational
mistakes that's
part of being a teenager most of us can
look back at our teenage years and say
we made some very irrational decisions
and that without the guidance and loving
support of our parents
and no one loves us more than our
parents in most cases
we would have made worse mistakes so to
rip that authority away from parents
is often the worst mistake that the
courts can do well that is always the
excuse isn't it
that we start from the assumption that
somebody who
perceives themselves as being
transgender is somehow making a mistake
that they don't understand their own
mind
that they're not capable of making a
rational informed decision
i would not particularly consider
somebody
15 or 16 to be incapable
of making an informed rational decision
not only are the parents being bullied
but their rights are literally being
stripped away from them
by the government in this in australia
teenage hood is an emotional time
puberty is an emotional time we're
literally pumping
with you know emotions and so to say
that a child
who's 12 years old has decided that they
want to identify a certain way and that
the parents
are now going to be forced to allow this
child to have hormone therapy i mean it
literally slaps in the face of what the
purpose of a parent
actually is the thing about this is this
is really politicians and black robes
making political decisions
when you consider the science the real
science um we know
that sometimes these decisions people
can regret
later in life let the child wait until
he's an adult to make a decision
that may affect his health his or her
health for the rest of their life if
they're just waiting a few years
the parents should be the ones who
lovingly walk them through this
not a doctor not a court no one should
trump the authority of a parent
in this situation in certain parts of
the uk
wales and scotland 16 year olds can vote
they can make a decision on who runs
this country they can be members of the
armed forces
they can pay taxes they can marry with
parental consent
if we're going to allow as a society 16
year olds to make
those very mature decisions in my
opinion
then it is absolutely outrageous to take
this bonkers old-fashioned view
that children are somehow the chattels
of their parents
they are not the fact of the matter is
most people who transition
transition successfully and
it helps their mental health their
physical health and their overall
well-being
of course like anything you have
you know one or two which regret it
that is quite rare and this thought that
the parents should be the divine
authority just because they gave birth
to their child is in my opinion
outdated and misconceived when a child
says to their parent
i believe that i'm a girl even if that
child is eight years old
and and they're physically a male the
the current prevailing practice is to
allow that child to determine
what they want to do going forward to
say anything different
is considered abuse the definition of
abuse is being conflated
and and being very hard used in a way
that's harmful to actual children who
are being abused
you can't consent to sex how on earth
can you determine
that you are old enough to want to have
a mastectomy at 12 and have your breasts
removed
or you want to have your gender
reassigned i mean these are things that
a 12 year old and a 13 year old don't
have the capacity to understand the
long-standing
uh implications of and how do we provide
a way out for children who are suffering
from gender dysphoria
what should happen if there's a conflict
with parents burdens should follow on
the parents to make
the best most loving decision for their
families there are two things going
against children
in these situations one is if they're
ripped from the loving arms of their
parents
and two is if they're forced to make a
decision too young that they might
regret
the suicide rates are astonishingly
higher for children that make these
decisions the younger they are when they
make these decisions the more high
the suicide rate is for them later in
life once they've transitioned so we
need to be very careful about these
children being exploited for political
reasons